hey guys it's Justine and today I'm
doing a very quick unboxing for you this
is the BTS samsung galaxy s 25 G phone
this is such a beautiful phone I cannot
believe how amazing it is this is the
color that I had wanted them to launch
initially when they first came out with
this phone in addition to the phone I
also have the galaxies BTS buds as well
I was just reading about this phone so
the pre-orders went live and may sold
out within an hour in South Korea that's
crazy
Samsung sent me this to check out I do
have to send it back so unfortunately it
is not mine to keep but at least I get
to show it to you guys also before we
get into this I just want to say I'm
thankful that Samsung came out with his
phone because for whatever reason I had
never listened to BTS before everyone in
the entire world will be talking about
how incredible they are and for some
reason I never listened but I decided I
was gonna check out the phone I should
probably take a listen to BTS and I was
absolutely blown away the first time I
really had listened to them was last
week when my sister and I were doing our
podcast and I was telling to her about
this phone and I thought I should
probably do some research about beauty s
because I already know a lot about the
samsung s xx girl what are you doing to
me LinkedIn I've a LinkedIn notification
back to BTS now if you're a BTS fan you
already know that they're incredible but
me as a person who did not know I now
know and I am so here for it I don't
want to say what any of my favorite
songs are yet because I'm still learning
I'm still researching you guys had sent
me a bunch of videos that was like a
crash course to learning about BTS I'm
so sorry I wish that I knew more but all
I have to say is I am here now and I
wish that I had found out sooner better
late than never
now let me show you this awesome phone
to reveal those little hearts were
actually right over the s20 logo
I don't normally look at paperwork but I
think there might be some exciting
BTS themed items in here oh yeah we have
stickers so it has all of the band
members names it also has some little
emoji icons here I believe in your
Galaxy so it comes with the stickers
what else is in here so do you think
that when I have to send this back to
Samsung that I I'm sorry I talked about
this person oops I forgot to put this
back Shh
just kidding out I'll give them back
it's a very important part of this phone
these they look like little business
cards but they're for each band member I
would guess me you call them fan cards
or something I'm not really sure what
the term would be they also have a
little heart on the back too like a
little holographic embossed heart don't
mind my injury all right so here's the
phone this color is so beautiful it's
like a hazy purple and what I like about
this is it's more of a matte finish so a
lot of phones tend to get smudgy when
they have like the glossy finish but
this is a really nice matte finish and
it's kind of like an iridescent rainbowy
color as well and you guys see that oh
and did we point out that there is a
heart right here featured by the cameras
I mean it's so let's turn it on I hope
it's charged yes what else is in here
we've got the standard earbuds power
charger I believe in your galaxy look
look me being a new fan I'm excited I
mean I've been a fan for what a week and
a half at this point
imagine being someone who is a huge fan
of BTS and this would be for me like
being a really huge cool fan so if the
tool came out with a custom Samsung
phone you better believe it I would be
there in a second
I love it I love the purple theme this
is like one of my favorite colors so all
the custom icons everything I absolutely
love it let's check out the galaxy buds
as well also a nice custom box oh wow
laughs this looks so great and here's
how they look next to each other this
also has a little heart over here at the
front of it so when you open it see that
there's a lot of stuff in here this
looks like it's a smart buds cover oh
this is cool you can wear this like
around your neck or even like a keychain
or something so we have more little
cards I think we might I love this so it
has each one of them wearing the galaxy
buds
[Music]
these never happen I don't know it's a
charging cable and some extra little
tips for the ear buds but I feel like
the only way to end this video to make
it just all come around full circle is
to put the ear buds in and listen to BTS
this is I'm actually watching a youtube
video this is bts's newest music video
that premiered I guess over a week ago
at this point but this is stay gold I've
listened to this one a few times I can't
let you guys hear what I'm listening to
because it's copy written but these
sound really good I feel like I'm
yelling yeah I'm yelling a little bit
this is all I feel a lot of streaming
games cuz I have headphones on so I
can't hear myself why I talk louder so
that I can hear myself it's a
beautifully shot music video I'll put a
link in the description although it has
so many views that I feel like everyone
in the world has already seen it so here
they are
I think a view out of what they look
like I think they look good I saw them
on on the band members and they look
incredible I also just love the purple
eye this is like one of my favorite
colors I actually have a computer that
is a purple camo you guys might remember
that I got a very long time ago logo in
the buds and everything Oh
vixx me wants an update oh okay do you
guys have any suggestions for songs that
I should listen to videos to watch
anything at all please leave them in the
comments below or feel free to send me a
tweet because I am currently doing a lot
of BTS research thank you guys for
watching and we also have a new podcast
out so make sure you guys go check that
out and I'll put all the links in the
description and if you guys enjoyed this
video be sure to subscribe hit the bell
and I think that's all I think that's
everything that YouTube wants you to do
let's do it the next video bye
[Applause]
[Music]